thank you
[Applause]
well thank you very much thank you it's
great honor to have you here and
today we witnessed the most evil and
heinous abuse of power in the history of
our country very sad thing to watch a
corrupt sitting president had his top
political opponent arrested on fake and
fabricated charges of which he and
numerous other presidents would be
guilty
right in the middle of a presidential
election
in which he is losing very badly
[Music]
it's called election interference and
yet another attempt to rig and steal a
presidential election more importantly
it's a
political persecution like something
straight out of a fascist or a communist
Nation
this day will go down and infamy and Joe
Biden will forever be remembered as not
only the most corrupt president of the
history of our country but perhaps even
more importantly
the president who together with a band
of his closest thugs Misfits and
marxists tried to destroy American
democracy
but they will
fin we will win bigger and better than
ever before
charging a former president of the
United States under the Espionage Act of
1917 wasn't meant for this
an act for a crime so heinous that only
the death penalty would do and
threatening me with 400 years in prison
for possessing my own presidential
papers which just about every other
president has done is one of the most
outrageous and vicious legal theories
ever put forward in an American court of
law
the Espionage Act
has been used to go after Traders and
spies it has nothing to do with a former
president legally keeping his own
documents
as president the law that applies to
this case is not
the Espionage Act but very simply the
presidential records Act
which is not even mentioned in this
ridiculous 44-page indictment
under the presidential records act which
is civil not Criminal
I had every right to have these
documents
The crucial legal precedent is laid out
in the most important case ever on the
subject known as the Clinton Sox case
you know what that means
after leaving the White House Bill
Clinton kept 79
audiotapes in his sock draw
they included discussions of U.S
military involvement in Haiti
discussions of U.S foreign policy both
defense and offense against Cuba
recordings of President Clinton's
conversations with
all of the many foreign leaders at the
time think of that sensitive facts about
trade negotiations taken from
presidential briefings discussions with
the Secretary of State about conflict in
Bosnia and much much more
very big stuff Not only was Bill Clinton
never even considered for criminal
prosecution based on the tapes he took
but when he was sued for them he won the
case
Judge Amy Berman Jackson's decision
States under the statutory scheme
established by the presidential records
Act
the decision to segregate personal
materials from presidential records is
made by the president during the
president's term
[Applause]
and in the president's
Soul discretion
you're surprised to hear that aren't you
any normal Administration even an
opposing one would consider that to be
the end
but not the corrupt Biden Administration
the Sox decision as it's known
also States quote the National Archives
and Records Administration or Nara
does not have the authority to designate
material as presidential records I don't
have the authority
Nara does not have the tapes in question
and therea lacks any right Duty or means
to seize control of them this is law
the president enjoys unconstrained
authority to make decisions regarding
the disposal of documents that's
unconstrained
to make that decision neither the
archivist nor Congress has the authority
to veto the president's decision
the presidential records act does not
confer any mandatory or even
discretionary Authority
or the archivist to classify records
under the statute this responsibility is
left solely
to the president of the United States
think of that that's the decision think
of that
now just think of that in other words
whatever documents the president decides
to take with him he has the right to do
so it's an absolute right this is the
law
and that is something that people have
now seen and it couldn't be more clear
they ought to dropped this case
immediately because they're destroying
the country
and this is why no other president even
those who kept far more documents than I
has ever
been even investigated let alone charged
with a crime
because the Sham indictment put forward
by the Biden Administration included
stage photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago
many people have asked me why
I had these boxes why did you want them
the answer in addition to having every
right under the presidential records Act
is that these boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes and everything
as can be seen in the picture where
someone not me
I wonder who it might have been
dumped one of the very neatly arranged
boxes all over the floor
they were full of newspapers press
slippings thousands of pictures
thousands and thousands of White House
pictures
the White House photographers some are
with us today they took so many pictures
and we saved all of them and they were
in those boxes
clothing memorabilia and much much more
I hadn't had a chance to go through all
the boxes it's a long tedious job takes
a long time
which I was prepared to do but I have a
very busy life I've had a very busy life
they make it more busy because you're
always fighting
and under the Sox decision
there seemed to be no rush I wasn't in a
rush because that decision was a law
the other picture that was so vile you
remember that one it was angry and
corrupt was the photo staged by the FBI
and those that raided Mar-A-Lago they
were
putting documents all over the floor
remember that famous picture all over
say confidential said presidentials and
all sorts of things and it was supposed
to be there like
it was that way when they raided it
wasn't that way they put them there took
the picture and released it illegally to
the Press
they took my medical records my passport
my birth certificate and apologized
they even brought a safe tractor this is
a professional safe cracker they brought
into Mar-A-Lago
and they broke into my safe and you know
what they found nothing there was
nothing there
zero
according to the presidential records
act which was a big deal
I was supposed to negotiate with Nara
which is exactly what I was doing until
Mar-A-Lago was raided by gun toting FBI
agents
I have security tapes of it I gave them
security tapes of everything
in a flagrant violation of the Fourth
Amendment of the Constitution which
protects the right against
unreasonable search
and seizure
[Applause]
and Sebastian you covered very well I
must say
very well I'm not the one who thinks I'm
above the law I'm the one that followed
the law I'm the only one
it's Joe Biden and his corrupt
Department of Injustice who think they
are above the law
never before have the two standards of
Justice in our country been more starkly
revealed
Joe Biden had troves of classified
documents from his time as vice
president and even as a senator
which was completely and totally illegal
in fact other Senators heard about it
Dick Durbin heard about it you have to
see his response there's no way that's
totally illegal took him as a senator
out of a skiff
they were shocked when they found out
they actually thought it was impossible
to do
Biden sent
1850 boxes
to the University of Delaware making the
search very very difficult for anybody
and he refuses to give them up and he
refuses to let people even look at them
and then they say how he's behaving so
nicely
many of Biden's classified documents
were in Chinatown DC Chinatown
which is shocking considering his family
receives so much money from China I
wonder how many times the
friends of ours from China review those
documents Chinatown DC
others were unsecured at his so-called
Penn Biden Center in Washington which
paid Biden approximately one million
dollars a year the money supposedly
coming from China and still other
classified documents were strewn all
over his garage floor were his now
famous Corvette is stored he's so proud
of that car
there was no security and the door was
left open
most of the time it was open all of
those classified documents all of those
documents strewn all over the floor
piled up like junk
unlike me who had absolute
declassification Authority as president
Joe Biden as vice president had no
authority to declassify and no right to
possess
the documents he had no right instead of
falling under the presidential records
Act
Biden's actions fell under a much
stricter Federal records act which has
very very tough
criminal penalties yet nothing happens
to Crooked Joe nothing happened have you
heard anything about the big search for
his documents no only me
most infamously of all Hillary Clinton
set up
an illegal private server in her
basement you never heard this story
with a deliberate intention of violating
public information laws so she could
hide her pay for play scandals at the
Clinton foundations or whatever
Hillary's to Advanced quantities of
classified and sensitive information on
her illicit server
some of it happened to Lake it leaked
into Anthony Weiner's computer remember
Anthony winter
into his computer you don't want to be
on his computer
and all of it was illegal
because thankfully
she was never president she didn't have
the powers to declassify
thank you
she didn't have the powers to declassify
it's a big difference and neither did
Joe you know Joe didn't have your mind
have a drink
[Applause]
it's a little bit cooler than it was but
it's pretty hot out here
thank you happy birthday happy birthday
great birthday
nice birthday it
nice birthday
wonderful birthday
they were saying happy birthday I was
with
I was with Eric and Laura the kids happy
birthday grandpa happiness oh great I
just got charged with they won 400 years
approximity if you add them all up a
fake a fake 400 years though thank you
darling that's so nice
it's a wonderful birthday
we're going to make it into the greatest
birthday of all we'll make it into the
greatest
when caught Hillary then deleted
and acid washed Nobody Does that because
of the expense but it's pretty
conclusive
33 000 emails in defiance of a
congressional subpoena already launched
the subpoena was there and she decided
to delete acid wash and then Smash and
Destroy her cell phones with a hammer
and then they say I participated in
obstruction
now think of it that's called
there's never been obstruction as Grave
as that she did this in the face of
everything and yet
nobody did anything about it
the FBI and the doj protected her did
not issue subpoenas did not use a grand
jury did not execute search warrants and
then the
corrupt head of the FBI James Comey
declared no reasonable prosecutor would
bring a case can you believe it
[Applause]
and there was just one of many items
Hillary Clinton broke the law
and she didn't get indicted
Joe Biden broke the law and in many
other ways we're finding out
and so far has not gotten indicted I did
everything right and they indicted me
but you know we're serving as a great
example and
the case of Bill Clinton's National
Security advisor remember that Sandy
Berger he was caught stealing classified
documents from the National Archives
very big ones very important ones by
stuffing them in his pants that's pretty
and putting them also in his socks and
he destroyed them and cut
the tape with scissors cut them all up
what Burger did was highly illegal but
he was given
nothing no jail time nothing nothing
happened there are countless other
examples Bill Clinton
who I happen to like hard to believe
right before I did this I was actually
quite friendly with him
nice guy they should have used him a
little bit more as an advisor on the
2016 election he said you know you
better get to Wisconsin you're going to
lose no we're not you better get to
Michigan you're going to lose no we're
not they did
Bill Clinton lost the nuclear codes and
absolutely nothing was done about he
lost the nuclear codes
the George W bush White House lost
22 million emails a record
Nara cannot issue a complete transfer of
any of the Bush records
a document shredding truck was spotted
on the way to
Dick Cheney's house can you imagine
Hillary Clinton took hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of furniture
China flatware rugs and more from the
White House
and she wasn't prosecuted how about that
when she took the furniture
and the China
How about if Trump did that you think
Trump would have a little problem
the horrific violations of my rights by
crooked Joe Biden's weaponized
Department of Injustice are Unthinkable
it's Unthinkable what's happened so bad
for our country
Democrats all
they lawlessly pierced
my attorney-client privilege with
lawyers what they did to lawyers what
they have done to our lawyers our
lawyers all of our lawyers they've done
things that were absolutely horrible and
unthinkable
the leaking has been unbelievable and
highly illegal they leak
we've learned more about
from The Washington Post New York Times
about the doj's boxes hoax it's a Box's
hooks
then from prosecutors themselves we want
to read about it you pick up the
Washington Post
which is not doing well or you pick up
the New York Times but they'll do better
now because of these things you know
this is the only way they survive but
they'll end up dying
but it's not supposed to be that way we
don't want to learn from the times we
don't want to learn from leaks we want
to learn from the people we're supposed
to learn from it's like a leaking sieve
in Washington
but we learned nothing about the Biden
bribery scheme or special counsel Robert
Herr's investigation Robert Herr is
doing the Biden investigation he's a
very respected very nice person
very nice person
mine's not such a nice person mine's a
deranged lunatic
which are many times the magnitude of
ours in both number and severity
that's the prosecutor that they gave he
has found nothing he totally exonerated
Mike Pence I'm happy about that Mike did
nothing wrong but he happened to have
classified documents in his house
but they exonerated him and Biden is a
different story I mean so much you have
to really think about what I said as a
senator he took all of those documents
it's unprecedented
the prosecutor in the case
I will quote our case is a thug I've
named him deranged Jack Smith
I wonder what his name used to be Jack
Smith it sounds so innocent doesn't it
Jack Smith what's his name Jack Smith
he's a very nice man he's a behind the
scenes guy
but his record is absolutely atrocious
he does political hit jobs he's
been known to viciously arrest a certain
Governor you know the governor
Bob McDonald of Virginia and absolutely
ruined his life and the life of his
family all these wonderful family
members I knew them
only to have the case overturned eight
to nothing by the Supreme Court he
destroyed that man and he destroyed that
family
and by the way
I will tell you I'm here and I love you
all
and we can take it
but what these thugs what these thugs
have done to my family is a disgrace I
will tell you that I say it to all of
the fake news because there's a lot of
it backwards
what they did to my family and that
young man right there
he's answered more subpoenas than any
human being in the history of the world
and you know what they have nothing
after all of those subpoenas literally
thousands of them
Congress
fake councils Mueller report all of this
all he did is answer subpoenas all the
time at least he's become very
experienced at that congratulations
But Eric is fantastic and what he and
Don Ivanka and Taho group that's what
they've gone through and these are
serious people
these are serious people but what he's
done to my family what they have done to
my family is horrible he also tried to
Railroad John Edwards on a completely
bogus legal theory that didn't hold up
in court
it's no wonder this raging lunatic was
shipped off to the Hague to prosecute
war criminals using globalist tribunals
not beholden to the Constitution or the
rule of law two things Jack Smith
clearly disdains you take a look at this
guy he looks like a thug
but then I watched him make a speech the
other day and he was trembling because
it wasn't his territory he feels much
safer
in the inner sanctums of the
Department of Injustice where he can be
in his room and scream at people
he's a raging and uncontrolled Trump
hater
as is his wife who also happened to be
the producer of that Michelle Obama puff
pieces total puff piece
this is the guy I've got
don't forget this persecution is being
done by the same weaponized agencies
that for seven years have been running
illegal psychological warfare campaigns
against the American people much as if
they were trying to destabilize a
foreign country from the russia-russia
Russia hoax to the no collusion Mueller
Witch Hunt
to impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the 51 lying
intelligence offers how about them
they said it's Russia disinformation and
they knew it wasn't which made about
According to some of the great pollsters
that are right here made from anywhere
from a 10 to 17 point difference and yet
we still got more votes than any sitting
president in history in the second
election
and we actually did much better in the
second election than we did in the first
election
the fake dossier
paid for by the Democrats how about the
fake dossier remember that one you think
that was easy to go home and say Hello
darling how are you when they read about
that
wasn't easy at all
spying on my campaign we caught them
spying on my campaign the FBI Twitter
files and so much more
it's all been a battle of disinformation
one thing after the other and all to
protect the radical left
Misfits
it's also no coincidence that these
charges against me came down the very
same day
evidence revealed Joe Biden took a 5
million dollar bribe from Ukraine took a
five million dollar abroad
but the FBI and the justice department
don't even want to talk about it
they showed something on television
tonight it had zero time on the three
major networks zero but my impeachment
had almost all the time I think I had
351 minutes they had no minutes
okay
I think a lot of people are going to
vote yeah I think a lot of people
[Music]
I will tell you I just left Miami and
I've never seen love in the streets like
that I've never seen it we've seen a lot
of love
I've never seen love like that because
they know they know what we all go
through they know what we've gone
through and they see it and they're
smart and you know many of those people
coming from Cuba Venezuela other
countries they've seen this happening to
their countries I used to say that
the United States if it keeps going this
way it's going to be Venezuela on
steroids and now we're buying oil from
Venezuela can you believe we have more
Liquid Gold under our feet than any
other Nation but we're buying tar
from Venezuela and we're refining it in
Houston the dirtiest worst oil probably
anywhere in the world
and we're refining it so you can imagine
what's going up in the air and all
beautiful stuff we're not taken out of
the ground and making a lot of money and
paying off debt and reducing taxes still
further which we were in the process of
doing
they want to distract from the real
Espionage and the real crime so let's
use president Trump to do so let's go
out and let's indict president Trump so
they don't talk about the five million
dollar bribe just yesterday Senator
Grassley revealed that the barisma
executive who allegedly paid the bribe
reportedly has crooked Joe
on tape they have 17 tapes I understand
that he must be a nice guy to deal with
right
the guy from barisma nice company
they got him and Hunter on 17 different
types supposedly but the FBI isn't
showing him
remember they impeached me for asking a
simple question about Biden's corrupt
dealings in Ukraine and now they see
that once again I was right I was right
I was totally right
Joe Biden and the radical left can take
foreign bribes
and be totally protected Republicans all
you must finally get tough you've got to
get tough you've got to get tough and
you got to show them
when you arrest your leading political
opponent we no longer have a democracy
when people are allowed to pour through
our open borders and our elections are
rigged our country is in very serious
trouble
when inflation is allowed to rage when
energy Independence and dominance it's
we had Independence and dominance we
were going to be soon very very dominant
within six months we're going to
dominate the whole world with energy
make a fortune we were going to be
paying off debt and lowering taxes at a
level that nobody's ever seen and they
came in and they ended it
but when that's taken away from us when
interest rates and taxes spiral upward
in an uncontrolled way
when murders are allowed to roam
murderers these are horrible Killers
murderers are allowed to roam the
streets of our democrat-run cities
unchecked
but the incompetent district attorney in
New York indicts Trump for a crime that
everybody agrees every pundit everybody
there is no crime
but murderers go out
and nobody ever even comes and knocks on
their door and they know they're there
and they know their rooms and they know
their locations and they're roaming our
cities all over and some of them are
coming in right now through our borders
but then you have a nation that as we
are is in serious serious decline we
have a nation in serious decline
if the Communists get away with this
it won't stop with me they will not
hesitate to ramp up their persecution of
Christians pro-life activists parents
attending school board meetings and even
future Republican candidates which they
do
we must end it permanently and we must
end it immediately now that the seal
so important is broken the seal is
broken by what they've done they should
never have done this
this was an Unwritten rule you just
don't
unless it's really bad
but you just don't but the seal is now
broken
in addition to closing the border and
removing all of the criminal elements
that have illegally invaded our country
making America energy independent and
even dominant again and immediately
ending the war between Russia and
Ukraine I'll have it ended in 24 hours
I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
in the history of the United States of
America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special prosecutor
and all others involved with the
destruction of our elections our borders
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State we
will obliterate
the Deep Stone and we know who they are
I know exactly who they are
they want to take away my freedom
because I will never let them take away
your freedom it's very simple
they want to silence me because I will
never let them silence you they want you
silent
and I am the only one that can save this
nation because you know they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
and I just happen to be standing in
their way and I will never be moving
on November November 2024 Justice will
be done we will take back our country
and we will make America great again
thank you God bless you all thank you
thank you very much great job thank